imagínense una planta que como todas las
plantas cartelería del sol durante el
día
pero a la noche ilumina
imagínense un banco de sangre para
transfusiones de emergencia pero de
sangre artificial
y que desatan o contagia enfermedades
imagínense un organismo capaz
y capturar el dióxido de carbono el del
efecto invernadero sacándolo de la
atmósfera
pero no sólo eso sino que además lo
convierte en una forma útil de energía
no sueñen más bienvenidos a la biología
sintética
la mayoría de ustedes seguramente no yo
a hablar de biología sintética pero la
mano a ir en los próximos años
biología es el estudio de la vida
y sintética no viene de breve resumido
sino de artificial que no está en la
naturaleza
los biólogos sintéticos diseñamos
organismos para que nos ayuden a hacer
algo
puede ser algo abstracto como estudiar
la vida
o palpable urgente cómo tratar una
enfermedad generar energía limpia o
detectar un contaminante
lo novedoso es como modificamos o
generamos nuevos organismos vivos y eso
lo hacemos mediante el uso el diseño y
la combinación de bloques biológicos
son bio bloques como rating luego mis
ladrillos
y cada cada vídeo bloque representa una
función podemos diseñar un beat o bloque
que al ponerlo en una célula genere el
color rojo
qué género olor a banana o que genere
hemoglobina de la sangre
todos los bio bloques están hechos de
adn que es el material en que se guarda
la información genética y son fáciles de
combinar unos con otros
entonces un investigador hace 10 100 10
mil bloques y los comparte con la
comunidad
y cada usuario los toma y los usa para
hacer su propio organismo con la función
que desea pero no sólo los usa también
nos modifica los combina les da otros
otros usos puede crear
y lo más maravilloso para quienes nos
apasiona la complejidad de la biología
es que funciona
ok tenemos una bolsa llena de funciones
encerradas envió bloques y qué hacemos
jugamos armamos desarmamos ponemos
sacamos reciclamos la evolución recicla
lo vio los sintéticos venimos a ser
recicladores cereales que reutilizamos y
combinamos bloques biológicos para usar
para ser organismos con funciones a
medida
esto puede generar un poco de miedo
entonces cada uno hace lo que quiere
no hay muchos controles por ejemplo las
empresas que fabrican adn
tienen bloqueada la posibilidad de
fabricar toxinas o patógenos para que no
se hagan armas biológicas y también los
laboratorios que trabajan en biología
sintética suelen abrir sus proyectos a
la sociedad
en mi laboratorio nos visitan
diseñadores industriales artistas
plásticos sociólogos y exploramos con
ellos esto de la biología sintética
el fuego quema
el agua ahoga pero no por eso dejamos de
usarlos es sólo cuestión de hacer un uso
responsable y seguro
ok pero de qué hablamos cuando hablamos
de organismos
a los seres humanos nos gustan las
mascotas algunos nos gustan los perros a
otros los gatos o los patos a los
biólogos sintéticos nos gustan las
bacterias y las levaduras que son
microscópicas y tenemos muchas
muchísimas
en la antigüedad doméstica vamos
microorganismos para ayudarnos a
producir alimentos como el pan como el
yogur o la cerveza hoy también los
usamos para fabricar remedios para
producir energía
para estudiar la habilidad pero no son
todos los usos posibles también
podríamos usarlo para ser más saludables
para vivir mejor por ejemplo podríamos
modificar alguno de los organismos que
viven adentro nuestro
si tenemos bacterias viviendo adentro
nuestro de hecho un ser humano sano
tiene unas 10 veces más bacterias
adentro suyo que células humanas a quien
se le hubiese ocurrido hace unos años en
tomar una bacteria para curarse de algo
hoy estamos aprendiendo a entender esas
comunidades de microbios que viven
adentro nuestro y a como usarlos para
vivir mejor
les quiero contar mi historia con la
biología sintética la primera vez que
escuché biología sintética
pensé estos son los chantas inventan un
nombre para conseguir plata o hacerse
los interesantes pero cuando entendí de
qué se trataba me deslumbró
si con la biotecnología vieja podríamos
recortar palabras de un organismo y
pegarlas en otro de una forma
artesanal y laboriosa con la biología
sintética podemos escribir reescribir y
editar un libro entero
tenemos todo el diccionario o más bien
toda una biblioteca en la computadora y
podemos combinar las palabras a voluntad
uno de los grandes hitos de la biología
sintética fue la fabricación del primer
genoma artificial muchos sabrán que la
información genética está en el genoma y
que se puede fabricar adn en el
laboratorio
hace 4 años en un laboratorio fabricaron
a partir de 4 botellas de componentes
químicos un genoma completo después lo
introdujeron dentro de una bacteria
transformándola en una nueva especie
es como cambiarle el disco rigido una
computadora y ponerle otro sistema
operativo
flor de herramientas y no hay que ser un
súper genio para usarla
la mayoría de los proyectos de biología
sintéticas están motorizados por
estudiantes de su entusiasmo y su
ingenuidad surgen proyectos
impresionantes
en el 2013 con un grupo de estudiantes
de la universidad de buenos aires
decidimos estudiar un problema que le
doliera a la sociedad y que pudiéramos
abordar con herramientas de biología
sintética
nos decidimos por el el problema
gravísimo de acceso al agua potable
cerca de 4 millones de argentinos
consumen diariamente agua contaminada
por arsénico principalmente los que
toman agua de pozo y no lo saben o quien
si lo saben no tiene una forma fácil de
medirlo nos propusimos entonces diseñar
un kit de fácil uso tipo un test de
embarazo que le permita al usuario saber
si el agua de su pozo tiene arsénico o
no
se acuerdan de los bio bloques bueno
combinamos la función detectar arsénico
con la función generar color lo juntamos
lo pusimos adentro de una bacteria y la
transformamos
en un sensor de arsénico un vídeo sensor
este proyecto lo hicimos en el contexto
de una competencia internacional de
biología sintética donde nuestro equipo
ganó una medalla de oro y el premio al
mejor modelo teórico
pero no nos quedamos sólo en el modelo
tomamos muestras de campos reales y
funcionó
el paso siguiente
es generar una carcasa que permita
contener esas bacterias y poder
distribuir ese dispositivo
este es el prototipo actual
una pone unas gotas de agua en un
pocillo
unos pone unas gotas de agua en un
pocillo espera unas horas y compara el
color que desarrolla ese depósito con
otros colores de referencia y así sabes
cuánto arsénico tiene en su pozo
me gusta verlo como un modelo inspirador
cuando uno no sabe que algo no se puede
hacer lo intenta pero cuando sabe que se
puede animar más hoy en día hay empresas
usando biología sintética para fabricar
esencia de vainilla usando biología
sintética para fabricar un remedio
contra la malaria o hasta para fabricar
tela de araña hoy en día podemos diseñar
organismos que nos ayuden a resolver
problemas es sólo cuestión de imaginar
imaginar un organismo que nos ayude a
cuidar el ambiente imaginar un organismo
que nos ayude a estar más saludables
imaginar un organismo que nos ayude a
generar energía limpia
porque ya sabemos en biología sintética
imaginar es poder gracias